CHRISTIANITY HAS A LONG HISTORY,
ALMOST AS LONG AS THE JEWS--
NOT THAT, OBVIOUSLY, NOT THAT
IT'S A COMPETITION OR ANYTHING.
WE'VE JUST OBVIOUSLY BEEN AROUND
FOR THOUSANDS OF YEARS LONG.
THE POINT IS THIS, WHAT IS THE
FUTURE OF CHRISTIANITY?
JORDAN KLEPPER INVESTIGATES.
>> CHRISTIAN CHURCH ATTENDANCE
IN THE UNITED STATES CONTINUES
TO DWINDLE, BUT ACCORDING TO THE
NEW YORK TIMES, THERE WAS ONE
PASTOR CARL LENTZ WHO WAS
DRAWING RECORD CROWDS
WITH AN INNOVATIVE STYLE.
BUT WAS HE THE REAL DEAL?
EXCUSE ME, YOUNG ROCK BAND
MEMBER, I'M LOOKING FOR A STUFFY
OLD PASTOR WHO SAYS HE HAS
A MODERN TWIST ON CHRISTIANITY.
>> I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
ME.
>> THIS IS WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
>> YEAH, YEAH. WE'RE GOING TO--
LET'S JUST HUG IT OUT.
>> YEAH, THAT. YEAH.
THAT FEELS RIGHT.
>> GREAT TO MEET YOU.
>> YEAH, GOOD TO HANG OUT WITH
YOU, MEET YOU.
>> YEAH. YEAH.
>> COOL.
WAS I FACE TO FACE WITH THE
FUTURE OF CHRISTIANITY?
FUTURE CHRIST.
COPYRIGHT JORDAN KLEPPER.
PASTOR LENTZ HAD IT ALL.
SKINNY JEANS, THE DOUCHE BEANIE
AND HE PLAYED GRAND THEFT AUTO
IN GORE MODE.
IN SOLD-OUT STADIUMS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THIS GUY HAD BOTH
BELIEVERS AND BELIEBERS.
IF YOU HAD TO DESCRIBE YOUR
CHURCH EXPERIENCE IN FOUR WORDS,
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE IT?
>> SUPER, SUPER, SUPER, DOPE.
>> YEAH.
SO IS THIS THE FUTURE OF
CHRISTIANITY?
>> I THINK, YEAH.
OUR CHURCH, WE'RE GOING TO GET
DOWN TO IT.
YOU CAN GET BIBLE VERSES ON YOUR
PHONE.
YOU CAN WATCH A LIVE LINK.
SO IF YOU CAN'T COME TO CHURCH,
YOU CAN, LIKE, GET ON YOUR SMART
PHONE.
>> OH, SWEET.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOME DOPE
BEATS.
>> YEAH.
>> RESPECT.
>> ONE LOVE.
>> COOL.
>> HOLLER.
ROCK ON.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO KEEP SAYING
THOSE THINGS.
CARL'S TURNING CHRIST UP TO
ELEVEN.
BUT BELIEVE IT OR NOT, SOME
RELIGIOUS LEADERS, LIKE REVEREND
DR. CHRISTOPHER BENEK, AREN'T
DIGGING ON CARL'S DOPE SAUCE.
>> I HAVE SEEN SOME HIPSTER
PASTORS AND I THINK THEY'RE
MISSING THE BOAT IF THEY'RE
TRYING TO SENSATIONALIZE
THE CHURCH.
>> SO WHAT DOES THIS GUY THINK
WILL REVOLUTIONIZE CHRISTIANITY?
>> ROBOTS.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING THE FUTURE
OF CHRISTIANITY INCLUDES ROBOTS?
>> POTENTIALLY.
>> HOW DOES A ROBOT BECOME
CHRISTIAN?
>> WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
A ROOMBA, OR YOUR iPHONE
OR TALKING TO SIRI.
WE'RE TALKING SOMETHING THAT'S
YOU KNOW EXPONENTIALLY MORE
INTELLIGENT THAN WE ARE.
SO ROBOTS WILL CHOOSE TO BE
CHRISTIANS.
>> YOU'RE SAYING ROBOTS.
GIVE THEM THE ABILITY TO HAVE
HIGHER THOUGHT, THEY WILL
CHOOSE CHRISTIANITY?
>> YEAH.
I THINK-- I THINK IT'S REASONED
ARGUMENT.
>> THIS SOUNDED AWESOME.
CARL MUST BE PUMPED.
DOMO ARIGATO MR. CHRIST!
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD
REALLY CARE ABOUT A ROBOT AT
ALL.
>> YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
FUTURE, THOUGH.
>> SO BE IT.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE STILL GOING
OLD-SCHOOL PRAYER.
>> BUT IS OLD-SCHOOL PRAYER THE
FUTURE OR WILL ROBOTS REMIX
THOSE JAMS?
>> IF YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PROCESS ALL OF THE INFORMATION
ON EARTH INSTANTANEOUSLY, YOU
COULD WRITE A PRETTY GOOD
SERMON.
>> SWEET.
>> YEAH.
>> A LITTLE BIT BETTER THAN A
GUY WITH A TATTOOS AND A KICK
DRUM.
>> YEAH, SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER AS
FAR AS INTELLIGENCE GOES.
>> HIPSTER PASTOR SLAM.
>> AM I MISSING SOMETHING?
LIKE, I DON'T UNDERSTAND-- LIKE,
A ROBOT IS CREATED -- I DON'T
THINK A ROBOT COULD HAVE FAITH.
>> SURE, ROBOTS COULD HAVE
FAITH.
ABSOLUTELY, WHY NOT?
THE HOPE WOULD BE YOU
KNOW BEINGS THAT WOULD
ESSENTIALLY LEAD TO US A NEW
PATH OF HOLINESS.
>> NEW PATH OF HOLINESS SOUNDS
FUTURE CRUNK, RIGHT.
I MEAN, CLEARLY JESUS IS IN
NEED OF A REBOOT.
IS THERE A NEW SON OF GOD WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING OUT FOR?
IS THERE A CODY.
>> I FEEL LIKE HE TRANSCENDS
TIME.
>> HEAR ME OUT --
>> OKAY.
>> FATHER, SON,
HOLY GHOST, AND CODY.
>> WHO'S CODY IN THAT?
>> EXACTLY, MAN, THAT GUY IS A
MYSTERY.
>> I PERSONALLY FEEL LIKE JESUS
ISN'T IN NEEED OF A REBOOT
AT ALL.
I THINK HIP STUFF GOES OUT OF
STYLE.
THAT'S THE THING.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
YOU'RE STILL WEARING FONZI'S
JACKET.
OKAY ROBO DORK, SHOW ME THE
FUTURE.
>> I THINK AS A SPECIES, THEY
CAN USE THEIR GIFTS TO FURTHER
JESUS' REDEMPTIVE PURPOSES.
>> ARE YOU CALLING A ROBOT A
DIFFERENT SPECIES?
>> YEAH POTENTIALLY, UNLESS
WE'RE INTEGRATED WITH THEM.
>> ( BLEEP ) ROBOTS?
>> NO, NO, NO. LIKE A CYBORG.
>> LIKE IF HUMANS ARE GOING TO
MAKE SOMETHING YOU BELIEVE
THEY'RE GOING TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO GIVE IT A GENDER
AND ( BLEEP ) IT.
CHRISTIAN ROBOTS ARE GOING TO
BLOW YOUR MIND.
I WAS SOLD SO I WENT TO BUILD MY
OWN SUPER INTELLIGENT,
RELIGIOUS ROBOT, AND FINALLY IT
WAS DONE.
IT WAS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND SO,
I NAMED IT ADAM.
AUTONOMOUS.
DIVINITY.
ANDROID.
( BLEEP ), I DON'T KNOW.
MONKEY?
AND ONCE HE DOWNLOADED THE
BIBLE, HE DID HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS.
>> WHERE CAN I BUY MY
HEBREW SLAVE?
>> YOU CAN'T.
>> SERIOUSLY.
>> SORRY, IT'S NOT AN OPTION.
>> THE BIBLE SAYS I CAN HAVE ONE
IN EXODUS 21.
IT'S HALF THE REASON I SIGNED
UP.
>> THIS WAS NOT GOING WELL.
>> CAN GOD CREATE SOMETHING SO
HEAVY HE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
LIFT IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT. I'M SORRY.
>> IF GOD WANTS TO QUIT SMOKING,
CAN HE HIDE CIGARETTES FROM
HIMSELF?
>> I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT. I'M SORRY.
>> WHY DOES GOD GIVE BABIES
CANCER?
>> IT'S NOT JESUS-- JESUS
ADVOCATE--
>> I'M SO CONFUSED. NONE OF THIS
COMPUTES.
>> OH NO! OH DAMN IT!
>> MY HEAD IS HOT.
>> DAMN IT, DON'T GO.
>> IS THAT STEVE JOBS?
>> NO, DON'T GO TO THE LIGHT!
DO GO TO THE LIGHT!
OKAY, CHRISTIANITY WASN'T FOR
HIM BUT MAYBE THERE'S ANOTHER
PATH.
>> PROSTRATE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK I'M DOING?
I'M PROSTRATING.
>> HEAD ON THE FLOOR.
>> HIS HEAD ON THE FLOOR?
OKAY, NEXT!
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
CAN I INTEREST YOU IN A FREE
STRESS TEST?
>> GO ( BLEEP ) YOURSELF.
>> ALL HE WANTS TO DO IS CUT OFF
THE TIP OF YOUR GROUNDING ROD.
>> FORGET THIS, I'M AN ATHEIST.
>> YOU KNOW, AESTHETICLY
SPEAKING,
IT REALLY CAN BE QUITE
APPEALING.
>> NO ONE TOUCHES MYSELF ROBO
JUNK.
>> FUTURE CHRIST! IS THIS TOO
MUCH?
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS TOO MUCH.